it's an incredible collection of
pictures from the golden age of space
exploration could be yours if you can
afford it
the collection going up for auction
right now includes a rare picture of the
first man on the moon in the first
space selfie riley carlson is in london
[Applause]
videos from the apollo 11 moon landing
and astronaut neil armstrong's first
steps
are iconic
but when it comes to many of the still
photos armstrong
isn't in them most of the astronaut
photographs that you see from apollo 11
are of buzz aldrin
this photo is one of the rare exceptions
a shot of armstrong at the spacecraft
near the end of the mission it's
expected to fetch nearly forty thousand
dollars at auction
and this was forgotten about uh in the
aftermath of the successful
mission and it was only rediscovered in
the eighties there was in fact a
photograph of neil
james hislop is overseeing the
christie's auction house online sale of
nearly 2500 photos from the space race
era and beyond
selfie enthusiasts will be over the moon
for this that's buzz aldrin on a 1966
gemini mission turning the camera on
himself
all the more impressive when you
consider the conditions
also under incredibly difficult
circumstances in the near vacuum of
space
in clumsy awkward astronaut
outfits managing the mission and
snapping the shots that still captivate
us to this day
riley carlson cbs news london
it was buzz aldrin who captured that
rare picture of neil armstrong
christie's auction house says most of
the pictures have been previously
unreleased
the auction is going to be online until
november 20th